morning all welcome to sky news
breakfast and after a turbulent week for
boris johnson it's been revealed a
senior conservative backbencher who
accused government figures of blackmail
and intimidation
will meet with police officers next week
william rank claims that individuals
within government intimidated mps who
questioned the prime minister's position
all this
as number 10 braces itself for the
expected delivery next week the sugray
report into lockdown parties in downing
street
speaking to the telegraph mr rag said i
stand by what i have said
no amount of gaslighting will change
that
the offer of number 10 to investigate is
kind
but i shall leave it to the experts i am
meeting the police early next week our
political correspondent joe pike has the
detail
the allegations that william rag made on
thursday morning were extraordinary
explosive he says that some of his
conservative mp
colleagues in particular those who
potentially want a vote of confidence in
boris johnson have been subjected to
bullying and intimidation that may he
argues constitute blackmail although
boris johnson and some of his cabinet
ministers have said they have seen no
evidence for that now in a story first
reported in the telegraph and confirmed
in a conversation i have had with
william ragg he says that next week
early next week he's meeting with an
officer a detective from the
metropolitan police to discuss these
allegations although that does not
necessarily mean an investigation will
be launched why is he doing this well
partly because he doesn't want to be
bullied himself he wants this to be
taken seriously there's certainly over
the last 24 hours been a pretty a brutal
briefing campaign against him that is
not abnormal here in westminster but it
certainly helps substantiate
some of his claims about the
culture within this place he's also
doing this because of course he believes
that a crime or crimes potentially have
been committed and this is clearly an
escalation in the battles that are going
on within the conservative party in
westminster battles that don't really
seem particularly sustainable at this
point and that is before we get to next
week where we are expecting that
all-important report from sue gray about
events and parties that have taken place
within uh government and in particular
with a number 10.
joe pike there
the united nations has condemned an
airstrike by a saudi-led coalition on a
yemeni detention center that has killed
more than 70 people
the facility which is in a stronghold of
the rebel houthi movement was struck on
friday but the saudi official news
agency is now saying the coalition was
not targeting the centre now the u.n
secretary general has called for an
investigation another deadly day in the
war between saudi-led coalition forces
and the houthi rebels which has been
going on since 2015. sky's middle east
correspondent aleister bunkel reports
these are pictures broadcast by a
houthi-controlled television channel but
it's clear what happened
the building has been totally flattened
they're picking through the rubble but
by now and with the resources they've
got there is little chance of finding
anyone alive
it was a detention center run by the
iranian-backed houthis that many of the
inmates were civilian refugees who had
been fleeing the fighting
we consider this a war crime against
humanity the world should take its
responsibility at this critical moment
in human history
we are witnessing many victims
the number of dead keeps going up one
local hospital treated around 200 of the
wounded but then shut its doors because
it couldn't cope anymore
the airstrikes are retaliation for
houthi drones that exploded close to abu
dhabi international airport on monday
killing three people
what we need is to
stop this virtuous circle in which
things get escalating one after the
other
what we need uh is to have as we have
been
proposing from long ago
a ceasefire together with the opening of
harbor and
airports
and then
the beginning of a serious dialogue
among the parties
this escalation needs to stop
yesterday there were huge protests in
the rebel-held capital sana as yemen
faces yet another phase of violence in
this long-running conflict
seven years of devastating war tens of
thousands dead
and yet still it goes on
[Music]
russia and the united states have agreed
to continue talks over the future of
ukraine slightly easing fears of
conflict in eastern europe russia's
foreign minister said he was waiting for
security guarantees from the u.s
which should be provided next week
the united states secretary of state
warned that any incursion across
ukraine's border would be a renewed
invasion
and would be met with a severe response
from there our chief correspondent
stuart ramsey reports
it's over a thousand miles long the
frozen border between ukraine and russia
is divided by trenches and in places a
thin metal fence and berm
the right-hand side is russia
a few miles away across freezing fields
and drifting snow thousands of russian
soldiers tanks and missile systems are
waiting for orders
ukrainian border patrol says they
continuously monitor russian movements
towards them
on the face of it they seem fairly
unfazed by the prospect
[Music]
as we film near the fence a russian
border patrol passed nearby
the two sides are that close
it put it in puts it in perspective how
close we are to russia because that is
the russian border security uh
patrolling um we've been with the
ukrainian side and there they are
on both sides right next to each other
as you can see
you didn't expect to see them i have to
be honest
but the ukrainians say that they do the
same job as them
and they do see each other quite often
of course not with the sort of
underlying tension
that the world is seeing right now
and that tension deepened here in the
regional capital harkief when ukraine's
president said he thought that this
country second city could well be
targeted by president putin if he
decides to invade
young professionals like victor and
julia say they like all their friends
are genuinely scared now
julia has volunteered to become a
battlefield medic
like on the edge
of something very terrible
and scary and so
yes
i i can say
kind of scared
you know russians living by a war but by
their huge imperial ambitions but
ukrainians
agree with victory a really peaceful
nation but in case if someone tries to
took our freedom again we will fight
back
quite what a full-scale invasion would
look like isn't known russian tanks
could come straight across these frozen
farmlands
what's equally unknown is for how long
the ukrainian army can resist
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine
[Music]
some of the days other news now and more
than 300 migrants attempting to reach
europe have been rescued by the italian
coast guard
their overloaded boat ran into
difficulty of the mediterranean island
of lampedusa those rescued included 17
women and six children
a new york police officer has been
killed and another injured responding to
a domestic disturbance
a suspect was also killed in the
shooting in harlem an anonymous official
said a call had come in shortly after 5
pm of a mother needing help with her son
the boyfriend of gabby potito admitted
to killing her in a notebook discovered
near his body in florida according to
the fbi
it's the first time that authorities
have firmly placed the blame of mrs
potato sorry ms potato's death on brian
laundry
jab cabs and booster buses what are they
well they're the latest initiatives
being rolled out to encourage people to
get their covered 19 jab sky's
millionaire vessel linovich is in the
newsroom for us and is standing by to
explain exactly what a booster bus might
be
indeed well the nhs says that vaccine
hesitancy isn't even why some people
simply hadn't got round to getting their
vaccine yet some simply can't afford to
get to their appointments they save so
for that reason they are rolling out
these free cabs for people in manchester
birmingham and certain boroughs in
london where the take-up has been lower
there's also going to be shuttle buses
taking people to appointments in
both surrey and somerset and free bus
strips in nottinghamshire suffolk and
blackpool and for those who need a
little extra encouragement well now
there are two brothers who are
pharmacists and canned but also have a
popular restaurant and they will be
giving out kebabs with each jab so the
nhs is really throwing everything in
order to bolster the vaccine uptake
ahead of plan b restrictions lifting
next thursday we know this is a
government that is relying on vaccines
entirely in order to live alongside
kermit and for that they will need near
universal coverage and they are hoping
that these latency centers will get them
at least some way towards that
melina thank you
uh well let's stay with covid and the
sub-variant of the omicron strain has
been designated as a variant under
investigation by uk officials known as
ba2 the number of cases is currently low
with omicron still the dominant strain
in the uk
professor mike tilde is an
epidemiologist at the university of
warwick and he joins us once again on
the programme professor good to see you
this morning um i wonder if we could
start with this sub-variant what is it
and how concerned if at all should we be
yeah so i mean for the first thing i
should say whenever these sorts of
things happen i do say that the virus
mutates all the time so throughout the
pandemic we have seen new variants or
sub-variants which kind of smaller
changes to the virus occur when these
happen most of these variants are
sort of no different from the previous
variants that have been circulating this
variant this sort of sublineage of the
of the omicron variant
is becoming well it's becoming the
dominant um sub variant in denmark
around about 50 of the cases now appear
to be of this subvarian it may be that
there's slight evidence that it's a
little bit more transmissible but given
that it's been circulating in the uk
since uh december it looks like even if
it is a little bit more transmissible it
doesn't appear to be that much more so
and also the evidence coming out from
denmark does seem to be that there is no
particularly increased risk of
hospitalization or that the vaccines
will be less effective so i think
not particularly of concern at the
moment but of course as with any
situation with these emergency variants
very important to monitor it over the
next few days to just really ascertain
what the risk is
good to have you putting that into a
little bit of context professor and so
let's let's talk shall we about the
relaxation of of covered restrictions we
have no we now understand that within a
well within a matter of a couple of
weeks we will be pretty much back to
normal in terms of the way that we live
our lives on the basis of the data in
terms of hospitalizations in terms of
deaths
is this the right point at which to to
move away from plan b
yeah i think it's a really hard call and
i suspect really not my place to say
whether it's the right time to move to
plan b or not looking at the data which
i think is sort of my role really we
look let's look at the cases
they are going down actually um in all
the regions now the north of england a
little bit behind other parts
of england and hospital emissions are
also on the way down now of course
important to point that point out that
any relaxation will slow that rate of
decline as has happened again throughout
the pandemic my hope is that now that
the cases have turned around that we
will be looking at purely slowing rather
than causing cases to increase again the
one um sort of caveat to this is what's
going on in schools and particularly
primary schools that we are seeing a
rise in cases amongst younger children
at the moment my hope is that this is
just a smaller surge as a result of a
return of children to school and over
the next few weeks we start to see those
turn around again but very important for
us to monitor that situation in schools
over the next couple of weeks
yeah just on that topic given that of
course so many of the so many children
particularly the under-12s will not have
been have been vaccinated is there a
risk as we start to learn to live with
covet as the prime minister and others
have said that you know under-12s could
essentially just serve to keep
[Music]
omicron or whatever might be the
dominant variant into the population
well of course the first thing we should
say on this is that um
children are relatively um sort of
low risk in terms of getting
getting severe symptoms should they get
infected and that still remains the case
but of course
if they are they are still a relatively
susceptible population and actually it's
interesting at the moment comparing the
situation between primary aged children
and secondary age children because of
course secondary school-aged children in
general over 12 are mostly vaccinated
and we're not seeing the same high
number of cases in secondary school aged
children as we are in primary at the
moment so
um there is obviously a concern that
there is spread amongst younger children
and hopefully we are just seeing a wave
now that will eventually turn over as we
get towards the spring but of course
with that susceptible population there
is a risk that infection will then
expose older people um sort of
indirectly to infection so really
important for us to monitor that
uh you may well have heard professor
just before you came on nearly
discussing with uh my correspondent our
correspondent colleague melania the
booster buses and the jab cabs just the
latest attempt to try and get people to
to take up the vaccine should we read
into this that there is some concern
that vaccination uptake in certain
communities in certain parts of the
country isn't quite what it could be
oh well i mean i've been sort of making
this point probably for about six to
nine months now that on the whole of
course on a national level vaccine
uptake has been fantastic and actually
the vaccine roller out for the last 12
months has been one of the sort of
shining lights of the vaccination of the
of the campaigns of the control campaign
in the uk so it has been incredible how
many people have come forward but of
course you're quite right that that is
variable there are certain communities
where uptake is a little bit lower and
booster vaccination campaign has gone
very well but there are still
hard-to-reach communities that do need
to come forward and access the vaccine
and the problem is that with high levels
of vaccine across the country if there
are certain communities where uptake is
low there is the risk of sustained
infection in those communities and
potentially risk to the more vulnerable
in those communities so it's very
important that the government does what
they can to get out and get to those
hard-to-reach communities and hopefully
improve vaccine uptake
professor mike totally from the
university of warwick good to see you
again thanks for joining us no problem
a few of the day's other news stories
now and new pictures have emerged from
tonga where life-saving supplies have
been delivered by new zealand's navy
boats docked in the island's capital
almost a week after a huge volcanic
eruption triggered a tsunami the ship
was carrying 250 000 liters of water and
the equipment to produce 70 000 more
liters every day
well as you can see there were somewhat
chaotic scenes in honduras's congress
after a brawl broke out during the
swearing-in of a new congressional
president members of the leftist liberty
party fought amongst themselves after
congressman jorge callix was elected as
congress president instead of louis
redondo
interesting story this a thirds of
motorists are not aware that the highway
code is changing next week according to
a survey by the aaa the code which
contains advice and rules for people on
britain's roads is due to the update
updated on the 29th of january with new
guidance for drivers on overtaking
cyclists or horses and more
responsibility to be aware of
pedestrians
the actor and former governor of
california arnold schwarzenegger has
been repo has reportedly been involved
in a car accident that left one person
injured
the 74 year old former bodybuilder was
in a yukon suv one of four cars involved
in the crash on sunset boulevard
the producers of james bond have said
the british actor idris elba is part of
the conversation to become the next
double 07.
barbara brockley addressed the
speculation over who will next play bond
after she was told a lot of fans want to
see idris elba in a tuxedo other actors
thought to be in the running for the
highly sought after role includes tom
hardy and henry
social media companies are under
pressure to remove anti-vaccination
material from their sites over fears
that young people could refuse vaccines
because of it
research has found that two-thirds of
anti-vax propaganda posted online is
created
by just 12 so-called influencers
uk ministers have been urged to take
tougher action such as introducing fines
to social media companies that spread
disinformation our political
correspondent kate mccann reports
the anger the fear the division with
covid19 has come a new anti-vaccination
movement distinct from those who are
vaccine hesitant anti-vaxx propaganda is
designed to do harm
the best anti-vaxxers are really good
marketers too so look the actual
algorithms that that underpin social
media platforms
they know that conspiracy theories are
sticky which is that once you've had one
you want to know more about it because
they're new they're exciting they're
different and so they feed you more and
more and we found that in our studies we
found the actual algorithm recommending
and feeding people more and more
conspiracy theories young people who
live more of their lives than ever
before online are prime targets for
anti-vaxxers and teachers worry the pull
of the internet is too strong to counter
without help from the government they
obviously look on social media they see
quite a lot of jokes i think on
instagram tick tock there's lots of
jokes about i'll get my vaccine and then
this happens to me i think it still has
an effect on them that they think well
actually you know instead of vaccines
being something quite dull boring and
necessary it's something that is
controversial weird and slightly
alarming ministers are promising tough
new measures including fines to stop
anti-vaxx videos online but they accept
policing the internet is a difficult
task internet is a large space and there
is definitely more to do and in fact in
the coming months we're going to be
introducing a piece of legislation the
online safety bill to go even further in
imposing statutory legal duties on
social media firms to make sure they act
in this area
labour says ministers must get tougher
legislation is a first unnecessary step
to this and it would send a clear
message to those tech companies that we
will not stand for inaction on
disinformation and misinformation
especially on something as important as
the covert vaccine i would urge
everybody to speak to registered medical
professionals if you are hesitant about
getting the vaccine please don't listen
to somebody on social media purporting
to know the truth
social media isn't real life some people
may never see anti-vaxx material but
those who do can find themselves sucked
in without realizing and it's changing
the way we think about medicine science
and whether we trust our politicians
kate mccann sky news
a benefit concert will be held at the
barbican in london tonight to raise
awareness and funds to support the
ongoing humanitarian crisis in
afghanistan
well the concert comes at a time when
the taliban have seized control of most
of the country performing at the ba
barbican will be the afghan-born rhubarb
player koma yoon saki along with sarah
karimi who fled the country with her
three nieces on august the 15th our arts
and entertainment correspondent katie
spencer reports
[Music]
[Music]
classical musician humayun saki was born
in kabul and plays the rebab the
national instrument of afghanistan
this weekend it will be heard on stage
at a benefit concert in london
but for those living in afghanistan it
is a sound they no longer get to hear
[Music]
posted on social media in charge once
more this is the taliban's reaction to
those who play music
honestly
when i saw that
i i in that time i feel like i
they are boring my heart
[Music]
our people
they need peace they need music
they don't have money and they don't
have anything to something will help
them
[Music]
when the taliban were last in power they
banned all forms of music making apart
from religious singing
now they've resumed control they've
already introduced a ban on music in
public places with many musicians
leaving afghanistan for their own
survival
[Music]
almost two decades after they were
ousted by a u.s led coalition as the
taliban took over kabul scenes at the
airport became increasingly desperate
from those that made it onto planes
relief
for those left behind this is what
replaced the music
[Applause]
mirawai siddiqui is a former director of
two music schools in afghanistan which
shut down overnight the faces of the
musicians and students seen here now
need to be blurred for their own safety
taliban
actually
officially announced that the musicians
have to change
their profession
so
they are not allowed to perform they are
not allowed to do any any musical event
they are afraid
[Music]
in hiding and without work in
afghanistan this winter campaigners say
musicians are starving to death and
there is frustration that while their
suffering made front page news last
summer now nobody seems to be listening
katie spencer sky news
[Music]
now i think it's fair to say netflix
became pretty popular during lockdown
with more of us staying home and binge
watching shows to pass the time but it
was a poor end to 2021 for the streaming
giant with a slowdown in subscribers
meaning its shares took a plunge and of
course it is not the only kid on the
block these days uh here to tell us more
about the world of streaming i'm joined
by tony morrellis from ampere analysis
tony great to see you this morning um
can we just start with
possibly the biggest question in all of
this why has netflix share place
had such a dramatic plunge i mean as i
understand it they're still putting on
subscribers just perhaps not quite as
many as they did hoped
yeah i mean we really can't comment
specifically on the share price uh but
generally speaking the ott space has
become a lot more competitive over the
past two years so in the past it was
just netflix and amazon dominating the
space now we get the new entrance from
disney from uh with disney plus of
course from warner media with hbo max
and uh paramount plus from viacom cbs
and others
so inevitably the the market is
becoming a lot more competitive and uh
that's at some extent reflected
so
it is a case that all of these new
entrants to the market everyone is
creating their own content these days
that's where perhaps you know studios
like netflix can perhaps you know steal
a march on their rivals
yeah they certainly have i mean netflix
has been producing original titles since
2013. in fact they've spent nearly 17
billion dollars since 2013 up until 2021
only on original content producing their
own like slate of um popular content has
been very successful and over the next
five years we actually expected amp
analysis that netflix is going to spend
about 50 billion more uh dollars on
content to basically continue bolstering
up their uh their content catalog
just in terms of of habits amongst the
viewing public i mean are people
sticking to one streaming service maybe
two
i won't tell you how many things i'm
subscribed to at the moment but it's
certainly more than i should be
yeah i mean
asphalt stacking or you know subscribing
to more than one service kind of dipping
in and out of the various uh content and
service that you want is a definitely a
common phenomenon some subscribers are
taking more and more services and just
commonplace now this is why you get uh
partnerships with pay tv operators and
ott sticks and that kind of stuff is
becoming very important because the
consumer ultimately wants a single
device to access all their content from
for the sake of convenience and ease
where are the growth markets then for
these streaming giants they must
continually be trying to identify new
market opportunities
one suspects that you know there are
still parts of the world where they
don't have perhaps the penetration that
they might have wanted
yeah of course i mean uh generally
speaking i mean if we look at netflix
and isolation for example in north
america around
half of the households in the in the
united states actually have an ethnic
subscription which is incredibly high in
western europe it's not quite as high
it's about one in three or it will be
around around that by the end of 2022
and obviously all the other markets are
a little bit further behind but outside
of the united united states where
perhaps it's hit a bit of a saturation
point but even their subscriptions are
growing there's plenty of room for to
grow for netflix and particularly in
developing markets where it's very
underpenetrated
well tony i take it from what you're
saying there we should not be
anticipating the demise of netflix as a
massive player in terms of global media
anytime soon oh absolutely not no
they're doing great in fact um even
though they're not necessarily growing
that many subscriptions in the united
states their revenues are doing very
well so in oh in 2021 they grew their
revenues by 11
while their subscriptions only grew by
two so even if they're not they're
they're not growing their subscriptions
at as high of a base it's not like
they're making any less money
tony maroulis from ampere analysis thank
you so much for joining us this morning
really appreciate it thank you
time to see how the weather is looking
this weekend
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
i mostly dry in settled conditions this
weekend however it will be rather cloudy
with just a few brighter spells most
places having a cloudy start some light
rain in the north there will be a patch
of frost and a few fog patches in the
south and the east fine and dry with
sunny spells in the cooler south and
east today elsewhere milder but cloudier
with some patchy drizzle over western
hills
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways with us this
morning to review the papers once again
the former editor of the daily star don
neesom and the broadcaster and writer
edward ado and edward we're coming to
you first this hour um story in the mail
online jeffrey cox unnamed people will
be familiar with i think the amount of
money that he earns frankly most people
will be unfamiliar with
so this is about um sir jeffrey cox he's
the um so yeah it's about the he was
embroiled in the second job scandal now
he's declared further earnings for some
work that he's been doing um and he
represented the british virgin islands
government in a corruption inquiry now
some may say you know if you're doing uh
secondary work uh depending on the
amount it's okay but i mean this is a
staggering nearly
1393 pounds an hour nearly uh i mean he
earned nearly 50 grand from this now
some have questioned whether you know
mps there should be a cap when it comes
to
second earnings or second jobs i mean
especially in the times that we're going
through a lot of people not
some people have lost their work and not
many people are able to earn that amount
and it's caused um control uh
controversy about this and i mean
it is a staggering amount i mean in
november the parliamentary commissioner
for standards catherine stone was asked
to investigate the earnings but that
that didn't take place and i'm not sure
whether this will sort of you know beg
the question for not just
parliamentarians or other mps to say
well look um in terms of us as seen by
the public you know is this a good thing
and whether there has to be a cap in
place because i mean his uh
he he earns over 81 000 so in a sense
if he does three or four days work he's
literally earning what he earns uh his
annual salary as an mp
yeah i will confess that i've always
been slightly confused as to how it
benefits constituents to have your mp
being paid to do another job um but
let's go shall we uh dawn to the front
of the independent and i suspect that
this will be a story that it doesn't
really matter which side of the
political divide you fall on it it has a
lot of truth to it bran boris damaged
irreparably by all this scandal
absolutely i mean yeah waking up again
to more boris you can't avoid boris he's
in every single newspaper interesting i
picked the independent because the
headline brand boris damaged permanently
by the scandal several scandals
obviously and it's interesting they call
him brand boris because
he is a brand isn't he i mean you know
out of all the the prime ministers we've
had i'm just trying to think of others
that could be you know class as a brand
and tony blair possibly certainly not
theresa may um but this is interesting
it's it's you know
has boris personally been completely
damaged by
partygate the hypocrisy uh david davis
uh you know who who said you know in the
name of god go um christian wakeford the
um the first impression from
the labour in 15 years
um and everything you know all the
scandals surrounding him and you know
the fact that we we do know that boris
tells lies and isn't quite sure what our
party is so this is basically an
interview with lord hayward who's a tory
peer and an elections gurus who knows
what he's talking about and he is saying
that basically
brand boris is irreparably damaged and
if boris is still in charge come the
next general election and i know we're
all waiting for that one aren't we um
the conservative probably will not win
because boris is there however nil he
does counter this by saying that
the bounce back from the vaccine roll
out which is the one huge success that
boris and the tory party can claim and
also the freedoms now that we have
emerged from certainly in england and i
know wilds scotland and northern ireland
are catching up with
the bounce back of the freedoms that we
now have and coming out of the pandemic
might just say boris's skin so it's a
balancing act on one hand you have all
the controversy and on the other hand
you have the feel good factor of coming
out of the pandemic hopefully please god
we stay out of it so it's going to be
very interesting but you know brand
boris is this the end and i think it's a
question that no matter what side of the
political debate you're on you're going
to be asking yourself certainly until
sue gray's report comes out on the
parties which is i think gonna happen
next week i am on tenterhooks for that
moment um edwards your story from the
mirror online actually quite a timely
one our correspondent andy hughes is a
special running all day today about
knife crime in london this ah a knifing
taking place inside selfridges of all
places
a place where many of us go to families
uh it would probably be a day out for
some families and
for that to happen for two people to to
be to be get involved in a fight and
they get stabbed it's just it's just
shocking and the problem with um
stabbings in london it seems to be
spiraling out of control already or last
year we had 30 deaths and over the years
i mean i've come across stories not just
from doing my radio shows but generally
talking about um the impact of knife
prime and how it can
what can be done in order to try and
defuse this but for this to happen the
center of london in oxford street it's
just worrying it's just shocking and i
mean they've been calls not just for the
mayor of london but for government to
take action to make to to try and defuse
this but i mean for this to kind of
happen um in the center of london where
tourists families in a well-known
department store um
i'm you know lost for words i just hope
that there is a a formula to try and to
eradicate this because it can't go on
any longer yeah you just hope that
london perhaps gets its act together in
the way that glasgow did a few years ago
with the violence reduction unit um don
take us to the times this is a this is
an interesting one because in fact
strangely enough i questioned uh quasi
quartering about it yet on the program
yesterday morning there are a number of
schools which are still continuing to
insist that their pupils wear masks
what's the pm saying about it
well the prime minister is telling
schools that they have to ditch face
masks in the classroom and this story
has been around all week as we know when
we were given our freedoms back earlier
on this week it was like
face masks in classrooms one of the few
things one of the first things to
absolutely go and in my opinion quite
rightly so i think children have
suffered enough and i think it does
affect their education and various
studies have backed that up however this
is nadeem sahabi the education secretary
is now overseeing plans by local
directors of public health to bring back
secondary school face coverings in areas
where there are covered 19 rises now he
is taking personal charge at this and
but he has said like you can make to
schools he said you can make a decision
about whether you um ask pupils to wear
masks in in communal areas in your
schools however if you are going to try
and enforce face masks back in the
classroom if there is a kobig peak in
your area you have to liaise directly
with me
naturally the education unions are doing
what they do and saying this is wrong
this is mad we can't do this etcetera
etcetera but the bottom line with this
is neil is that you know 80 percent of
pupils feel that wearing a face covering
affects their education and surely the
most important thing here is after the
two years that they have had that that
students of all ages
certainly those coming up to their exams
this year and we know they've been
messed about so much actually get back
to getting a proper education
edwards i really want you to squeeze in
this story from paige page 37 of the
daily mail you know you're going for the
big stories when it's age 37
yeah eminem's gold walls go on you've
got 30 seconds
this has blown my mind that i've never
seen m m's in this light apparently
they're having a revamp because they
need to make themselves more friendly
more diverse i mean chocolate is
chocolate right now but apparently
it's not the case so they're having a
revamp because apparently one of the
characters uh is deemed to be too sexy
and the other one doesn't look right and
it it it makes it anxious i don't know
where we're going so which is which
edward because i'm a bit confused which
one's the sexy one so apparently the
green one is too sexy and possibly
flirts with the brown one i mean can you
help me out with this neil i mean it's
chocolate no um actually no i can't i'm
afraid